now this this morning the priest in
charge of Paris's Notre Dame Cathedral
says the landmark nearly destroyed by
Monday's fire will be closed for five or
six years 21st century technology will
likely be pivotal to its reconstruction
a New York professor made these 3d
digital scans of Notre Dom accurate to a
fraction of an inch
Jericka Duncan shows how this research
along with a videogame could be the
foundation for the cathedrals
restoration Jericka good morning good
morning really amazing what technology
could do over several years one
architecture historian at Vassar College
used still photography and laser
technology to create a digital 3d
archive of Notre Dom but what began as
an attempt to better understand its
gothic structures could now prove
invaluable to rebuilding the classic
Cathedral take a closer look at this
intricate reconstruction of no true DOM
you're seeing more than a billion points
of data collected with laser scanners
like this one to reveal structural
nuances a normal picture never could
that's thanks to the work of Vassar
College art professor Andrew Talon who
died in November this pinnacle is coming
apart Talon was a tireless advocate for
notre dame's renovation his work to
digitally scan the cathedral is finding
new relevance today he and this building
will forever be completely linked in my
mind
Lindsey Cook was one of talyn's
colleagues and former students at Vassar
it is the only place where we have that
data preserved the beauty is they can be
used in new ways in future generations
in 2015 Talon gave a behind-the-scenes
look at how he collected data at the
National Cathedral in Washington what
the laser scan actually does is it sends
out a beam so it generates a whole cloud
of data points that's extremely rich
professor Cooke walked us through some
of Talon snotra dom data points so what
are we looking at here we're looking
here at a cross-section of the nave roof
she said it took him roughly two years
to compile images combining his scans
with High Definition pictures like these
to make his 3d models look as accurate
as
no Troodons digitally influenced future
may find inspiration from a popular
video game as well artists from 2014
Assassin's Creed unity reportedly also
spent years digitally modeling the
landmark just like talon what do you
think the biggest takeaway is from these
models certainly it's wonderful to have
a document that is a digital
preservation or a digital archive of
this entire structure now after the fire
a top EU communications officials said
preserving with digitization is
important for us and for future
generations Cooke told us that Vassar
has not been approached by talons
research but says his conceivable that
he will be getting those renderings or
that they will get some people reaching
out about those renderings meanwhile
Frances prime minister says an
international architects competition
will be held to rebuild that amazing
spire so really cool story that we got a
chance to shoot and learn think about
that technology yeah and I wonder what
other landmarks like that might as an
insurance policy do the same thing today
great thank you very good sir